we grew up in the same town we both
Brookline Massachusetts so yeah I grew
up on Winthrop Road
Winthrop wrote your own Salsbury right
no we're actually on well I could say it
on TV yeah hard road yeah
else I can they're probably going over
there now to burn it down I went to
Driscoll school and Brooklyn yeah my
music teacher mrs. Steele would talk
about you yes sorry mrs. Steele no
kidding Jesus and this is a weird start
to it we've just said it's good that
someone's gone what's what's backup
start again okay so Brookline high you
my first day of freshman year they
played your valedictorian speech or a
speech you gave that they've played all
of us for our first day of freshman
years like this is what you could be
that's so embarrassing
I don't know I just they totally found
out later on that they I gave us talk
there when I was a writer on The
Simpsons they invited me back and I gave
a talk and then they they show it they
make them all come into a giant room the
first day and make them watch this thing
which of course is horrifying because
then you become the chore yeah everybody
else so yeah I remember sitting through
it wondering when I was gonna end
[Laughter]
nightmare day just a nightmare of a day
you